I really love your stand-up and I think
that you just have a bright future
I understand that but you know what
things take time it was Bobby but like
you just did a pilot for ABC BS form
freeform ABC with our friend Benji yeah
what's his last name are following all I
can't say it falafels who's blind he's
legally blind
yeah I mean it I I know but he when he
takes his glasses he has to rub his eyes
so much and yeah he cries a lot you guys
yeah and what's great about being it you
know my age and at the Comedy Store is
is that I've always been able to like go
to open mikes and see because this
Comedy Store the staff they're all
comedians it's such a tight-knit family
almost that I was able to see Esther and
all these people grow you know in the
business and it's really just um I just
realized that now that it's a blessing I
guess how old were you when you came to
LA 21 and you came from Chicago right
yeah and then you started doing stand-up
right away or do you start yeah no I
started right away here that's when I
met you yeah the store and I have I been
mean to you you know you have never I
Drive you crazy
but you are like yeah your jerk like why
well like what why I just like I feel
like nights out when we're getting food
you just like you'll tell a story and
then at the end we'll all be like soem
into it and excited and engrossed and
then at the end you'll be like I made it
all up you're out to torture yeah but
it's like
you'll also give it'll be so so generous
to the point where like one time years
ago you're wearing a shirt it sounds
like that shirt is so cool like where'd
you get that I want you just took it off
and gave it to me yeah which like
because I am I'm a special person yeah
you are shut up [ __ ] everyone giggles
[ __ ] you George everyone [ __ ]
right you don't even [ __ ] know dude
no it's I'm a Dreamweaver dude well the
thing is at the Comedy Store when you
first get there like the older kids or
the seniors as you know in my head like
they're scary and they don't really talk
to you yeah like hey zo yeah but you I
feel like we're very welcoming to all
the freshmen I am but I'm very picky
though if I see a young guy and I just
in the bottom of my heart believe that
they have no chance if they just I mean
in a way that I'm like I scare myself
because I want to be nice to people but
I'm so cold will you say to them I loved
him you could tell though with ng yeah
because they you brought him to the
store I did you know I'm though I
brought Kevin Christi he had never done
stand-up before about him to the store I
convinced Matt Edgar to stand on this
stay in aromantic
what's that little [ __ ] Mexican or
whatever that from Florida what's her
name the girl Kim Congdon she's Puerto
Rican whatever God whatever Mexican ID
she goes I'm going back to college I go
if you do your careers over she then she
quit college and she lived in LA but you
also say this to everybody you mean we
talked about it the last episode we [ __ ]
isn't false he gives a lot of people
false hope and it's it's a it's a
chronic syndrome of his I don't you know
what about you saying that now really
puts my throne and already you just
admitted to I know but now when I think
about what you're saying now is you're
absolutely [ __ ] wrong okay tell me
yeah because the stuff that I do with
other people are like you know the
people that I wanted to stop talking let
me get out of the situation it's pretty
much like a 101 statement that I always
say you know I just gotta follow your
dreams or whatever whatever right but
that's like [ __ ] what when I say
people to people quit going to college
and move to LA I think I pretty much
mean it mmm-hmm you know and I meant it
to where I I think aster should stay in
it and that's that you know
[Music]